All right guys, so now we are going to learn the Asian session liquidity trading strategy.
So let me type that in Asian liquidity, Asian session liquidity trading
strategy. Let me put this like this. All right, perfect. So what is Asian session liquidity trading
strategy? Well, during the Asian session price, most of the time consolidates. Okay. So it's
going to be like this and blah, blah, blah. Right. So let's suppose that this is an Asian session.
All right. This is the start of the Asian session. And this is the end of the Asian session.
All right. There you go. Perfect. This is the end. So
if once the Asian session is over, we get a one to two hours time period of
lunch. Okay. So let me draw this out like this. Once the Asian session is over, we get this one
our break or to our break before London session starts. Okay. Now, during that break,
I want the price to pull back and create another high, high or lower low, depending on where the
price is going. All right. And once it does that, what you want the price to do is to break
or do do a market structure shift, okay, or change of character, whatever you want to call it.
Now the price can also break the structure after the London session starts. Okay. The only thing
that you should be focusing on that the fake out like this happens during the lunch time period.
Okay. Now it doesn't matter when price does a market structure shift or change of character
within that lunch period or during the London session. All right. Once that market structure
shift has happened, you want to identify auto block plus fair value gap. You want to go short,
put your stop plus right above there. And you want to target the low of the Asian session. Okay.
So what's price going to do is going to go back up. And then it's going to take out the
low of the Asian session. All right. Similarly, let me draw this. Let me remove this.
Do, if you're looking for buys during the lunch period, I want to see price
fake out. And then a clear, a very clear market structure shift.
We take our entry from the imbalance and fair value gap and we target the high of the Asian
session. Very simple guys. Okay. You do not need you do not need any daily buys for it.
It's an algorithmic trading strategy. So we see a market structure shift right around here.
Okay. And we got the fair value gap right around here or auto block. Okay. We take our entry here
and we target the Asian session liquidity high. So let me remove this. And let me show you an
example. Okay. So you can see we created the lower low, lower high, lower low, higher high.
But then we created another low low. And then we did not create anything. These were just wicks.
Okay. We did create this level and we brought, we created another level. So after that, you can see
that price faked out during the lunch period. And now what you want to do before we even start,
you want to, how do we identify a Asian session, a London session, and the lunch breaks and all.
You want to go to the indicator tab. You want to type in FX and Asian session range. Once you do
that, you want to go to the settings tab here. You want to go to the style settings and you want
to disable labels and lines. That is it. So the blue one is an Asian session. The green one is the
London session. And the gray one is the New York session. All right, clear. All right. So let's move
on. Now what do we have here? We got this market structure shift. And we broke a lot of structures,
right? So this shows us that price want to go up and take out the high of the Asian session. All
right. So what we do here is that we want to mark out the fair value gap and the autoblock. So as
you can see, this is an autoblock with fair value gap. You want to enter from here. You want to put
your stopwatch right below that autoblock and you want to target the high. Okay. Now you must
always take all of your profits when the high is taken out because price can reverse heavily.
Okay. So let me give you a few or more examples.